Acerca de la Simplicidad. Que gran manera de comenzar.
Primero que todo, he estado observando esta tendencia
en la cual tenemos libros como "Tal y tal para Dummies"
¿Conocen estos libros?, ¿estos "Tal y tal para Dummies"?
Mis hijas me comentaron que yo soy muy parecido, así que esto es un pequeño problema.
(Risas)
Pero, estuve buscando en Internet en Amazon.com otros libros como este.
¿Saben que existe algo llamado la Guía del Completo Idiota?
Hay una clase de modelo de negocios alrededor de esto de ser estúpido de alguna manera.
Nos gusta hacer que la tecnología nos haga sentir mal, por alguna extraña razón.
Pero eso realmente me gusta, por lo que escribí un libro llamado "Las Leyes de la Simplicidad".
Estuve en Milán la semana pasada, para su lanzamiento en Italia.
Es como un libro de preguntas -- preguntas acerca de la simplicidad.
Muy pocas respuestas. También me pregunto a mi mismo, ¿Qué es simplicidad?
¿Es buena? ¿Es mala? ¿Es mejor la complejidad? No estoy seguro.
Luego de escribir "Las Leyes de la Simplicidad",
estaba muy cansado de la simplicidad, como pueden imaginarlo.
Y entonces en mi vida, descubrí que
las vacaciones son la habilidad más importante para cualquier clase de persona que se desempeña por encima de lo esperado.
Porque las compañías siempre les quitarán sus vidas,
pero nunca podrán quitarles sus vacaciones -- en teoría
(Risas)
Entonces vine al Cabo el verano pasado para esconderme de la simplicidad,
y fui a la tiendas Gap porque sólo tengo pantalones negros.
Fui y compré unos pantalones cortos de color khaki o lo que sea,
y desafortunadamente su eslogan era "Manténlo Simple".
(Risas)
Abrí una revista y el eslogan de Visa era,
"Los Negocios Requieren Simplicidad".
Revelé unas fotos y Kodak decía "Manténlo Simple".
Por lo tanto me sentí un poco extraño ya que la simplicidad parecía estar siguiéndome.
Entonces, enciendo la TV, yo no veo mucho la TV,
pero ustedes conocen a esta persona -- esta es Paris Hilton, aparentemente
Y ella tiene este programa, "La Vida Simple".
Así que lo vi. No es muy simple, es un poco confuso.
(Risas)
Entonces, busque un programa diferente para ver.
Y abri esta guía de TV,
y en el canal E! este show "La Vida Simple" es muy popular.
Lo repetirían una y otra y otra vez.
(Risas)
Por lo que era traumatizante, realmente.
Por eso quería escapar de nuevo, entonces salí hacia mi automóvil,
y en Cape Cod, hay caminos idílicos -- y todos nosotros aquí en la sala podemos conducir.
Y cuando conduces, estas señales son muy importantes.
Es una señal simple, dice "Vía" y otra "Vía acercándose ".
Y conduzco mayormente en sentido recto, bien, y luego veo esta señal.
(Risas)
Por lo que pensé que la complejidad me estaba atacando repentinamente,
y pensé, "Ah, la simplicidad -- muy importante".
Pero luego pensé, "Oh, la simplicidad, ¿Cómo sería si estuviera en un playa?
¿Qué tal si el cielo fuera 41 por ciento gris? -- ¿No sería el cielo perfecto?"
Quiero decir, ese cielo con simplicidad.
Pero en realidad el cielo se veía como este, era un cielo bello y complejo.
Saben, con los rosados y azules. No podemos evitar amar a la complejidad.
Somos seres humanos y amamos las cosas complejas.
Amamos las relaciones. Somos muy complejos. Por lo tanto amamos este tipo de cosas.
Estoy en este lugar llamado el Laboratorio de Medios.
Quizá alguno de ustedes, amigos, haya escuchado acerca de este lugar.
Fue diseñado por I. M. Pei, uno de los más importantes arquitectos modernistas.
Modernismo significa caja blanca y es una perfecta caja blanca.
(Risas)
Y algunos de ustedes, amigos, son empresarios, etcétera.
El mes pasado estuve en Google, y ¡Dios mío! ¡Esa cafetería!
Ustedes, amigos, tienen cosas aqui en Silicon Valley como las opciones de participación accionaria.
Vean, en la universidad obtenemos títulos, muchos títulos.
El año pasado en TED, estos eran todos mis títulos. Yo tengo muchos títulos.
Yo tengo un título asignado como padre de un grupo de hijas.
Este año en TED, me contenta informar que tengo nuevos títulos
adicionales a mis títulos anteriores.
Otro Director Asociado de Investigación.
Y esto sucedió también, por lo que ahora tengo cinco hijas.
(Risas)
Es mi bebé Reina. Gracias.
Y por lo tanto mi vida es mucho más compleja gracias al bebé, realmente.
pero eso está bien. Seguiremos casados, creo.
Pero -- mirando hacia atrás cuando yo era un niño --
ven, yo creci en una fábrica de tofu en Seattle.
Puede que a muchos de ustedes no les guste el tofu porque no han probado un buen tofu,
pero el tofu es un buen alimento. Es un tipo de alimento muy simple.
Es un trabajo muy duro hacer tofu.
Cuando niño acostumbrabamos levantarnos a la una AM y trabajar hasta las seis PM, seis días a la semana.
Mi padre era algo así como Andy Grove, paranoico por la competencia.
Por lo que con frecuencia, siete días a la semana. Negocio de familia significa niños trabajando.
Eramos un gran ejemplo. Por lo que adoraba ir a la escuela.
La escuela era magnífica, y quizás el ir a la escuela
me ayudó a llegar a este Laboratorio de Medios. No estoy seguro.
(Risas)
Gracias.
Pero el Laboratorio de Medios es un lugar interesante y es importante para mi
porque como estudiante, yo era un estudiante de ciencias de la computación,
y posteriormente en mi vida descubrí el diseño.
Y estuvo esta persona, Muriel Cooper.
¿Quén conoce a Muriel Cooper? ¿Muriel Cooper?
¿No era maravillosa? Muriel Cooper. Ella era excéntrica.
Y ella fue una expositora en TED, exactamente, y nos mostró --
ella mostró al mundo como hacer bonita la computadora de nuevo.
Y ella es muy importante en mi vida,
por que ella es la que me sugirío dejar el MIT e ir a la escuela de arte.
Ese fue el mejor consejo que he recibido. Por lo que me fui a la escuela de arte, gracias a ella.
Ella murió en 1994,
y fui contratado de nuevo por el MIT para intentar cubrir su espacio, pero es muy difícil.
Esta persona maravillosa, Muriel Cooper.
Cuando estuve en Japón -- Yo fui a una escuela de arte en Japón --
Tuve una agradable situación, por que de alguna manera estuve conectado con Paul Rand.
Algunos de ustedes, amigos, conocen a Paul Rand,
el mejor diseñador gráfico -- Lo siento --.
El gran diseñador gráfico Paul Rand:
diseñó el logotipo de IBM, el logotipo de Westinghouse --
el dice básicamente, "He diseñado de todo"
Y también Ikko Tanaka fue un mentor muy importante en mi vida --
el Paul Rand de Japón. Diseñó la mayoría de los principales íconos de Japón
como la marca Issey Miyake y también Muji.
Cuando tienes mentores -- y ayer
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar habló sobre mentores,
esas personas en tu vida -- el problema con los mentores es que todos mueren.
Esto es algo triste, pero realmente es algo feliz de algún modo,
porque puedes recordarlos en su forma pura.
Pienso que los mentores que conocemos nos humanizan.
Cuando te vas haciendo mayor y estas un poco enloquecido , o cualquier cosa,
los mentores te calman.
Yo estoy muy agradecido con mis mentores y estoy seguro de que todos ustedes también.
Porque lo humano es muy difícil cuando estás en el MIT.
la T no significa "humano", significa "tecnología".
Y por eso, siempre me he preocupado acerca de esta parte humana.
Siempre he realizado búsquedas en Google sobre la palabra "humano",
para descubrir cuantos resultados obtengo.
Y en el 2001 obtuve 26 millones de resultados, pero para la palabra computadora,
porque las computadoras estan un poco en contra de lo humano,
Obtuve 42 millones de resultados. Permítanme hacer algo al estilo de Al Gore aquí.
Si ustedes hacen algun tipo de comparación, como esta,
verán que computadora-versus-humano --
He estado haciéndole seguimiento en el último año --
computadora-versus-humano ha cambiado a lo largo del último año.
Solía ser de dos a uno. Ahora, los humanos se están recuperando
Muy bien, nosotros los humanos: nos estamos recuperando con respecto a las computadoras.
En el reino de la simplicidad, también es interesante,
de manera que si comparan las complejidades con la simplicidad,
también se esta recuperando de alguna manera.
De manera que, los humanos y la simplicidad estan entrelazados, creo.
Les tengo una confesión: Yo no soy un hombre de simplicidad.
Yo pasé la primera etapa de mi carrera haciendo cosas complejas.
Muchas cosas complejas.
Escribi programas de computadoras para hacer gráficos complejos como este.
Tengo clientes en Japón para hacer cosas realmente complejas como esta.
Y siempre me he sentido mal con respecto a ello en algún sentido.
De manera que me escondí en la dimensión del tiempo:
Creé cosas en una dimensión tempo-gráfica.
Elaboré esta serie de calendarios para Shiseido.
Este es un calendario con un tema floral en 1997,
y este es un calendario sobre fuegos artificiales. Donde lanzas el número en el espacio,
porque los japoneses creen que cuando ves fuegos artificiales
te sientes mas frío por alguna razón.
Por eso ellos lanzan fuegos artificiales en verano.
Una cultura muy extrema.
Por último, este es un calendario basado en el otoño,
porque tengo muchas hojas en mi patio.
Por lo que esto son las hojas de mi patio, esencialmente.
Y así realizé muchas cosas de este tipo.
Fui muy afortunado de haber estado alli antes de que otras personas hicieran esta clase de cosas,
e hice toda esta clase de cosas que confunden a sus ojos.
Me siento un poco mal por ello.
Mañana, Paola Antonelli va a dar una charla; Yo adoro a Paola.
Ella esta realizando esta exhibición justo ahora en el MoMA
donde algunos de estos primeros trabajos se estan exhibiendo en el MoMA, en las paredes.
Si están en Nueva York, por favor, vayan a verla.
Pero he tenido un problema porque hago estas cosas voladoras.
y las personas dicen: "Oh, conozco tu trabajo"
tu eres el tipo que hace caramelos para la vista".
Y cuando te dicen eso, te sientes algo extraño.
"caramelos para la vista" - algo peyorativo, ¿no creen?
Por lo que yo digo: "No, yo hago carne para la vista" por el contrario.
(Risas)
Y carne para la vista es algo diferente, algo más fibroso,
algo más poderoso, quizá. Pero ¿Qué pudiera ser eso, carne para los ojos?
He estado interesado en los programas de computadora toda mi vida, realmente.
Los programas de computadora son esencialmente árboles,
y cuando haces arte con una programa de computadora, hay un problema.
Cuando haces arte con un programa de computadora,
siempre estás en el árbol y la paradoja es que
para lograr un excelente trabajo artístico, tienes que estar fuera del árbol.
Este es un tipo de complicación que he encontrado.
De manera que para salirme del árbol, comencé a utilizar mis viejas computadoras.
Llevé esto a Tokio en 2001 para crear objetos computarizados.
Esta es una nueva manera de tipear, en mi vieja Classic de color.
No puedes tipear mucho con esto.
También descubrí que un ratón infrarojo responde a las emisiones CRT
y comienza a moverse por si mismo, de manera que esta es una máquina auto-dibujante.
Y también un año, la G3 bondi azul.
esa cajita sería puesta a la venta, como, peligrosa, como, "whack", asi.
Pero pensé, "Esto es muy interesante. ¿Qué sucedería si hago como una prueba de choque de autos?"
Entonces hago una prueba de choque.
(Risas)
Y algo asi como una medición del impacto. Cosas como esas son las que he hecho.
algo asi como para entender que son estas cosas.
(Risas)
Poco después de esto, sucedió el 11 de Septiembre y estaba muy deprimido.
Estaba muy interesado en el arte contemporáneo
que era acerca de liberarse a si mismo y cosas realmente tristes,
y por lo tanto yo quise pensar acerca de algo feliz,
así que me enfoque en la comida como mi área --
ese tipo de cosas como el pelado de una clementina.
En Japón, es algo maravilloso quitarle la cáscara a un clementina
en una sola pieza. ¿Quién a hecho eso antes? ¿Una clementina de una pieza?
Oh, amigos ustedes se lo están perdiendo si no lo han hecho todavía.
Fue muy bueno y descubri que puedo hacer esculturas con ella,
realmente, en diferentes formas.
Si las secas rápido puedes hacer cosas como elefantes, novillos y otras cosas,
y a mi esposa no le gustaron porque producían moho, por lo que tuve que dejar de hacerlo.
Entonces volví a la computadora y compré cinco porciones de patatas fritas,
y las digitalicé con el escáner. Y estaba buscando algún tipo de tema relativo a la comida,
y creé un software para componer automáticamente imágenes de patatas fritas.
Y cuando niño, escuche una canción, saben,
"Oh bello, por amplios cielos, por ondas ámbar de cereales."
por lo que creé esta imagen de ondas ámbar.
Es algo asi como un campo de maíz del medio oeste hecho de patatas fritas.
Y también cuando niño, yo era el más gordo de la clase,
por lo que solía amar los Cheetos. Oh, amo los Cheetos, deliciosos.
Entonces quise jugar con Cheetos de alguna manera.
No estaba seguro de a donde quería llegar yo con esto. Inventé la pintura Cheetos.
La pintura Cheetos es una manera muy sencilla de pintar con Cheetos.
(Risas)
Descubrí que los Cheetos son un buen material expresivo.
Y con estos Cheetos comencé a pensar,
"¿Qué puedo hacer con estos Cheetos?"
Y comencé también a arrugar y retorcer patatas fritas en hojuelas y también pretzels.
Estaba buscando algún tipo de forma,
y al final realicé 100 butter-fries (juego de palabras: mariposas - patatas fritas). ¿Entienden?
(Risas)
Y cada butter-fry está compuesta de distintas piezas.
Las personas me preguntan como se hicieron las antenas.
Algunas veces las personas encuentran un cabello en la comida, pues ese es mi cabello.
Mi cabello está limpio, Está bien.
Yo soy profesor titular, lo que significa, básicamente, que no tengo que trabajar más.
Es un extraño modelo de negocio. Puedo venir al trabajo cada día
y engrapar cinco hojas de papel y sólo observarlas con mi café latte.
Fin de la historia.
(Risas)
Pero me di cuenta de que la vida puede ser muy aburrida,
por lo que he estado pensando acerca de la vida y me di cuenta de que mi cámara --
mi cámara digital versus mi auto -- una cosa muy extraña.
El auto es muy grande y la cámara es muy pequeña,
aunque el manual de la cámara es mucho más grande que el manual del auto.
No tiene ningún sentido.
(Risas)
Estuve en el Cabo una vez y escribí la palabra "simplicidad",
y descubrí, en esta extraña manera a lo M. Night Shyamalan,
que descubrí las letras, "M-I-T", ¿Conocen la palabra?
En las palabras "simplicidad" y "complejidad", "M-I-T" ocurrían en perfecta secuencia.
Es un poco misterioso, ¿cierto?
De manera que pensé que puede ser que haré esto por los próximos veinte años o algo asi.
Y escribí este libro, "Las Leyes de la Simplicidad" --
es un libro muy corto y sencillo. Tiene diez leyes y tres claves.
Las diez leyes y tres claves, no voy a hablar sobre ellas porque por eso escribi el libro,
y también por eso es por lo que está en la web de manera gratuita.
Pero las leyes son como el sushi de alguna manera; hay de todo tipo.
En Japón, dicen que el sushi es desafiante.
Saben que el uni (sushi de erizo de mar) es el más desafiante y el numero diez es desafiante --
las personas odian el número diez como odian el uni, realmente.
Las tres claves son fáciles de comer, entonces es anago (sushi de anguila), ya cocido y fácil de comer.
Disfruten entonces su plato de sushi luego con las Leyes de la Simplicidad.
Dado que se las quiero simplificar.
Porque de eso es de lo que se trata. Tengo que simplificar esto.
Entonces, si simplifico las Leyes de la Simplicidad,
Obtengo algo que es llamado la "galleta versus la ropa lavada".
Alguien que tenga niños sabe que si le ofreces a un niño
una galleta grande o una pequeña,
¿Cual galleta van a escoger? La galleta grande.
Puedes decirles que la galleta pequeña tiene trozos de chocolate Godiva,
pero eso no funciona. Ellos quieren la galleta grande.
Pero si le ofreces a los niños dos pilas de ropa lavada para doblar,
la pila pequeña o la pila grande, ¿Cual seleccionarán?
Extrañamente, no la pila grande. Así que que pienso que es tan sencillo como esto.
Saben, cuando quieres más, es porque quieres disfrutarlo,
cuando quieres menos, es porque se trata de trabajo.
Y por lo tanto, para resumirlo, la simplicidad es acerca de vivir la vida
con más disfrute y menos sufrimiento.
Pienso que esto es algo asi tan sencillo como más-versus-menos.
Básicamente, siempre depende.
Este libro lo escribi porque quiero descifrar la vida.
Amo a la vida. Amo estar vivo. Me gusta ver cosas.
Y dado que la vida es una gran pregunta, pienso en la simplicidad,
porque ustedes están tratando de simplificar sus vidas.
Y yo amo ver el mundo. El mundo es un lugar maravilloso.
Al estar en TED vemos muchas cosas al mismo tiempo.
Y yo no puedo evitar disfrutar al ver todo en el mundo.
Como todo lo que ves cada vez que te despiertas.
Es una gran alegría experimentar todo en el mundo.
Todo desde un extraño lobby de hotel,
hasta un envoltorio plástico colocado sobre tu ventana,
hasta este momento donde el camino enfrente de mi casa está pavimentado de un color negro oscuro,
y esta polilla blanca estaba allí muriendo en el sol.
Y así, todo esto me ha hecho pensar en lo emocionante de estar aqui,
porque la vida es finita.
Esto me lo dió el presidente de Shiseido.
Es un experto en envejecimiento. El eje horizontal es que tan viejo eres --
doce años, veinticuatro años, setenta y cuatro, noventa y seis años --
y estos son algunos datos médicos. Así la fortaleza del cerebro se incrementa hasta los 60,
y luego después de los 60, comienza a declinar. Algo deprimente.
También, si observan en su fortaleza física.
Saben, tengo muchos estudiantes de primer año engreidos en el MIT, por lo que les digo:
"Oh, sus cuerpos realmente se están haciendo más y más fuertes,
pero a finales de los veinte y mediados de los treinta, las células, mueren".
Bien. Esto los hace trabajar más duro, a veces.
Y si tienes visión, la visión es interesante.
Mientras envejeces desde la infancia, tu visión se hace mejor,
y puede que al final de la adolescencia, comienzo de los veinte, estás buscando una pareja,
y tu visión anda tras eso.
(Risas)
Tu responsabilidad social es muy interesante.
Asi que mientras más envejeces, puede que tengas niños, lo que sea.
Y luego los niños se gradúan y no tienes más responsabilidades --
eso es muy bueno también.
Pero si alguno de ustedes pregunta,
"¿Qué es lo que realmente aumenta? ¿Algo aumenta?
Cual es la parte positiva de esto, ¿saben?" Pienso que la sabiduría siempre aumenta.
Yo adoro a esos hombres y mujeres de ochenta años, noventa años.
Ellos tienen tantos pensamientos y tienen mucha sabiduría,
y creo -- saben, esto de TED, he venido aqui.
Y esta es la cuarta vez y vengo aqui por esta sabiduría, creo.
Este efecto TED, eleva su sabiduría, de alguna manera.
Y estoy muy alegre de estar aqui y muy agradecido de estar aqui, Chris.
Y esto es una maravillosa experiencia para mi también.